President Trump has not spoken directly
about the killing but he did tweet this
image of an American flag shortly after
the attack major Garrett is at the White
House for US major good morning
if drone strike comes as a surprise yes
this is a surprise it is reverberating
that surprise that is across Capitol
Hill and the world now president Trump
quite clearly has been willing to pursue
high-value terrorist targets as
president but he's also looked for ways
not to expand either in numbers or
duration US military involvement in the
Middle East negotiating with the Taliban
seeking to withdraw US forces from
Afghanistan and recently pulling some US
Special Forces out of Syria but this
move marks a critical 180-degree turn
for president Trump and it comes as he
campaigns for reelection and faces a
possible Senate impeachment trial
analysts also fear it draws both the
United Nation the United States and Iran
closer to war and dramatically risk
increases risks rather for Americans in
the Middle East and possibly elsewhere
now it's worth noting back in 2011 and
2012 mr. Trump criticized then President
Barack Obama for his Iran policy choices
tweeting don't let Obama play the Iran
card in order to start a war in order to
get elected president Trump also
withdrew from the Obama era Iran nuclear
deal in May of 2018 he reinstated an
expanded economic sanctions on the
Iranian regime that drew ire for both
Iranian leaders and the supreme leader
Ayatollah Khomeini who subsequently
rebuffed the president's initial offer
to meet and try to negotiate new terms
of that Iran nuclear deal in a tweet
prior to Suleiman Eze assassination at I
told Himani said quote meaning to
America you can't do anything and your
crimes in Iraq have made nations hate
you
well president Trump has proven what US
intelligence and the US military can do
the risk is he believes Iran is either
too weak politically economically or
militarily to respond Anthony that is a
risk previous president george w bush
and barack obama were unwilling to take
a major thank you
you